I've been trying to sort of find some
silver linings in terms of the election
of President Donald as the guy who will
be running the White House and will have
both the House and Senate also under
Republican control for at least two
years if not longer and one of the
silver linings I pointed out is that my
sense is that not all progressives but
some progressives if Hillary Clinton had
one on november eighth would now be sort
of resting on their laurels for at least
the next two but more likely for years
thinking hey we don't have to do that
much because hillary clinton's in the
White House and the reality is that
Hillary Clinton would have been center
left to Center to maybe center-right in
some ways and also she still wouldn't
have had the house nor the Senate and
progressives would have needed to be
really active either way and now
everybody knows that the next four years
we've got to be really active that's
that's one thing the other silver lining
and I I've been talking to some other
independent progressive hosts over the
last couple of days is that since the
election of Donald Trump but independent
progressive media really has exploded
and I know that we get trolls every day
on our on our YouTube channel saying
David your show is ending because you
guys just lost but the reality is the
david pakman show has never been bigger
I mean we had into numerous consecutive
days pat on YouTube where we had a
thousand new subscribers each day to the
YouTube channel after the election of
Trump we've not seen numbers like this
for really ever for this consecutive
period of time yeah it was a pretty
crazy to watch it seems like Trump maybe
actually quite good the economy after
all yeah right the debt that's the
argument summer making any way that
people have been telling me that um but
so this this is a good thing in the
sense that we now realize corporate
media completely failed as I told you
that we didn't hear about Bernie Sanders
from corporate media until it was like
embarrassingly too late where corporate
media had to talk about the guy podcast
downloads have been blowing up and I've
talked to some other hosts saying the
same thing youtube views have been
blowing up and other hosts have been
saying the same thing new members we by
the 13th of this month and now we're
near
the end of the month by the 13th of this
month we had already surpassed the new
monthly member record that we ever
experienced previously in an entire
month in just the first 13 days this
month so I believe that progressives
will be better positioned for twenty
eighteen and twenty twenty then if
everything else was the same
house-senate disastrous corporate media
coverage etcetera except Hillary Clinton
was in the White House now that doesn't
mean that Donald Trump is not going to
try to do and probably succeed at doing
some horrible things during his
presidency absolutely but the silver
lining is I believe progressives are
prepared and on that note we are going
to be launching a major fundraising
initiative soon and I will give you more
details soon but the idea will be we
need to grow beyond just being the david
pakman show the TV radio and online show
we need to grow into being a catalyst
for progressive activism we're gonna be
creating the position of a progressive
engagement coordinator that is going to
be participating not only in helping our
audience actually coalesce around issues
and individual elections and candidates
and causes but coordinating a broader
group of progressive independent media
shows so many great things are going to
be happening we're going to be doing it
and I think that this is the the
opportunity to do it of the last many
years in the meantime you can get the
2017 david pakman show calendar this is
something that we've been offering a
calendar this the third straight year
now the theme this year uh is a sort of
a coloring book cartoon style all art by
by david pakman show viewer dan burke
and you can get this either alone or
with a membership for free at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 and if
you're sort of not into the calendar but
you just want to do something to support
independent media but normal membership
prices are a little bit high you can use
this coupon code i voted 17 not actually
gonna check whether you voted by the way
somebody emailed me and said david i use
the code but i didn't vote hey you're
you're still voting with your dollars by
being a member you can go to david
pakman.com slash membership and use that
coupon code i voted 17 that
we'll make a monthly membership only
three dollars and sixty cents and that
uh is a level at which many more people
have been adding their support so we're
just trying to find the silver linings
here in the election of President Donald
and a Republican House and a Republican
Senate and likely right wing Supreme
Court pics etc etc and if we can
strengthen independent media and prepare
ourselves for the next four years then
that is at least something